ludo bonjour et merci d'être en direct
sur rt france alors pourquoi avoir saisi
le conseil d'état vous pensez que le
gouvernement sait des choses sur
l'origine du coronavirus je ne sais pas
si le gouvernement c'est les jo ce que
je déplore c'est que le gouvernement
dans une période aussi difficile que
nous connaissons le devoir impérieux de
transparence
il ne doit pas garder le silence dans
lorsqu'on lui pose des questions aussi
graves que celles gp pose n'est pas
remonté nicolas dupont aignan lie à
d'accord franco chinois qui date
d'octobre 2004 que je connais bien cet
accord est une véritable arnaque
politique au profit kachine puisqu'on se
blesse et notre technologie de notre
savoir faire à leur profit on leur
confie les clés de tous et de tous et du
souss et schultz de virus et on
abandonne totalement le suffit de ce
laboratoire groix ne sais pas une vidéo
qui est sonné au hasard il ya des
événements qui se sont produits qui
permettent d'avoir des questions à poser
on pose des questions m'ont abordé alors
les réponses qu'on doit les de l'ex-site
à devoir impérieux de les donner
tout tir chaud de ces temps on peut dire
j'ai totalement abandonné le suivi de ce
laboratoire
on peut dire j'ai des connaissances mais
je ne donnerais pas mais dont l'ancien
député qui est un représentant du peuple
doit effectivement avoir des réponses de
la part des citoyens qui seraient alors
maintenant il ya une double question
aujourd'hui qu'est posée
la première c'est que nous devra avoir
des réponses et la deuxième c'est qu'un
ministre qui est questionnée par écrit
n'a pas l'obligation de répondre
ils peuvent garder le silence et ça
c'est une injure
la démocratie c'est un jour la
démocratie c'est un vide juridique que
j'essaie de faire combler devant le
conseil d'état et j'espère devant le
conseil constitutionnel en disant qu'il
ya manifestement un problème dans notre
constitution qui ne donne pas de
sanction qui ne permet pas de donner aux
citoyens des outils des outils
démocratiques pour contre un ministre a
répondu aux questions de la députée et
c'est l'enjeu de ce de cette requête que
j'ai déposée au nom de cette association
alors vous avez déclaré justement que le
silence de l'elysée vers eux étaient
inadmissibles ils posent question est ce
que c'est un silence s'étaient peut
nourrir un certain nombre de fantasmes
selon vous justement ce silence on
entasse nourrit les complotistes
et ça c'est très mauvais dans la période
que nous connaissons une période de
stress terrible et de morts et de
malades
donc je veux justement mettre fin à ce
complotisme à ceux d'août à ces
suspicions
il faut que nous ayons une transparence
sur le fonctionnement de ce laboratoire
je rappelle que les chinois avaient
l'obligation dans le calme cet accord de
rendre compte à l'eau et baisse chaque
année de l'exploitation de ce
laboratoire et je sais lorsque j'ai
questionné le maire ce que les chinois
n'ont jamais donné la moindre
information est et l'om est curieusement
et de façon très étrange n'a jamais
demandé de rapport à la chine donc nous
voyez que nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une omerta de mehrtens alité d'une
gravité absolue et je pense
effectivement tous les français
aujourd'hui veulent savoir comment ce
virus se comporte
quel est son mode d'action nous avons
nous développons depuis le mois de mars
des présence continuelle de mes sens et
serristes sur les chaînes de télévision
en continu qui viennent dire lab landes
tba l'autre gris clair l'autre qui
conseille les guéguerres entre monsieur
restera août et les autres font que nous
sommes donc dans les câbles stress et
que ce stress doit cesser et ses raisons
pour laquelle j'ai déposé cette requête
alors on sait que le conseil d'état
devrait rendre sa décision sous 48
heures on l'a dit aux états unis une
enquête a été ouverte justement pour
connaître un petit peu l'origine de ce
virus vous souhaiter la même chose en
france
la france n'a pas les moyens d'assurance
n'a pas les moyens de mettre en place
des class actions de mes confrères
américains et j'espère que c'est que la
section blonde aboutit elle arrive
d'abord stif les états unis montrent des
satellites de surveillance des délits
militaires qui passe régulièrement au
dessus de la chine notamment de cette
ville de roanne il suffit de demander la
déclassification des renseignements
militaires collectés par ses satellites
et nous saurons ce qui s'est passé dans
ce laboratoire chose s'il ya eu ou non
un incident et on pourra j'espère mettre
fin à toutes les suspicions et à tous
les actes de complotiste le peu de nous
que nous subissons également chaque jour
merci beaucoup en tout cas emmanuel
ludot d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat de
l'association de patients union
nationale des associations citoyennes de
santé